ANNOUNCER: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
HERBERT GROSS: Hi, last time I
left you dangling in suspense
when I said what happens if the
terms in a series are not
all positive?
In other words, the trouble with
the last assignment was
that we did quite a bit of work
and yet there was a very
stringent condition.
Namely, that every term that you
were adding happened to be
a positive number.
Now obviously, this need
not be the case.
And the question is, can you
have convergence in a series
in which the terms are
not all positive?
And what does it mean, by the
way, if this is the case why
we stressed the situation
of positive series?
And this will be the aim of
today's lecture to straighten
out both of these points.
At any rate, I call today's
lesson 'Absolute Convergence',
and I hope that the meaning of
this will become clear very
soon as we go along.
But to answer the first question
that we brought up,
let's take a series
in which the
terms are not all positive.
Now, by the way, I will do more
general things in our
supplementary notes
on this material.
I felt though that for a
blackboard illustration, I
should pick a relatively
straightforward example and
not try to generalize it.
Let's take the specific series 1
minus 1/2 plus 1/3 minus 1/4
plus 1/5, et cetera.
And how do we indicate the
n-th term in this case?
Notice that the denominator
is 'n'.
The numerator oscillates
between minus 1 and 1.
And you see the mathematical
trick to alternate signs is to
raise minus 1 to a power.
You see minus 1 to an even
power will be positive 1.
And to an odd power,
negative 1.
The idea here is since for 'n'
equals 1 we want this to be
positive, we tacked on
the plus 1 here.
You see in that case, 'n' being
1, 'n plus 1' is 2.
Minus 1 squared is 1.
And at any rate, don't be
confused by this notation,
it's simply a cute way all
of alternating signs.
At any rate, what do we have
in this particular series?
We have that the terms
alternate in sign.
We also have that the n-th
term approaches 0.
Namely, the numerator
alternates between
plus and minus 1.
The denominator is 'n'.
So as 'n' increases, the terms
converge on 0 as a limit.
And finally, the terms
keep decreasing
monotonically in magnitude.
In other words, forgetting about
the fact that a plus
outranks a minus in terms of a
number line, notice that the
size of 1/3 is less than
the size of 1/2.
In other words, this particular
series, which is
called an 'alternating series',
has three properties.
It's called alternating
because the terms
alternate in sign.
The n-th term approaches 0.
By the way, we saw in our first
lecture on series that
the n-th term approaching
0 was necessary, but not
sufficient for making
a series converge.
However, what our claim is that
if in addition to this we
know that the terms decrease
in magnitude, our claim is
that the given series
will converge.
In other words, what I intend
to show is that 1 minus 1/2
plus 1/3, et cetera,
does converge.
And the way I'm going to do
that is geometrically.
I'm not going to try to prove
this thing analytically.
But as I've said before, the
analytic proof virtually is
just an abstraction of what
we're doing over here.
Let's take a look and see
what happens over here.
Notice that our first
term is 1.
Our next term is 1/2.
Our next term is 1 minus 1/2
plus 1/3, which is 5/6.
What I'm driving at is that if
you compute the sums, 1 minus
1/2 plus 1/3 minus 1/4, et
cetera, in the order in which
they're given, what you find
is that the sequence of
partial sums is 1, 1/2, 5/6,
7/12, 47/60, 13/20.
Now the thing that I want you to
see, the reason I'm waving
my hand here and why I think
this helps in the lecture is
look what's happening.
You see because the terms
alternate in sign what this
means is that as I start with 's
sub 1' over here, the next
term will be to the
left of 's sub 1'.
Then the term after that
will be to the right.
Then to the left.
Then to the right.
They keep alternating
this way.
Moreover, since the terms
decrease in magnitude, it
means that each jump is less
than the jump that came
immediately before.
In other words, as I jumped from
here to here, when I jump
back I don't come back
quite as far.
In other words, what I'm doing
now is I'm closing in.
You see the odd subscripts and
the even subscripts are sort
of segregated.
You see what's happening
over here?
And finally, because the limit
of the n-th term is 0, it
means that this spacing--
see the difference between
successive partial
sums is the n-th term.
That must go to 0.
In other words, our limit
'L' is in here.
And as 'n' increases, the
squeeze is put on and we get
the existence of a limit.
For example, whatever
'L' is, it must be
between 13/20 and 47/60.
By the way, I say this in
the form of an aside.
It turns out--
and for those of us who haven't
seen this before, it's
a very mystic result.
That's why I say, who'd
have guessed it?
It turns out that 'L' is
actually the natural log of 2.
And the reason I point this
out is that again, you may
recall that in our notes
we talked about 'Cauchy
convergence', meaning what do
you do when you don't know how
to guess the limit?
You see, the idea here is notice
that this particular
series converges.
But we don't know what the limit
is other than the fact
that it's being squeezed
in over here.
You see here's a case where we
know that a limit exists, but
it's particularly difficult
to explicitly name
what that limit is.
But that fact notwithstanding,
is it clear that because of
the fact that the terms
alternate, the magnitudes
decrease, and the limit is 0
that these things do converge
to a limit?
I think it is clear.
But the next question, and I
apologize for what looks like
slang here, but I think this is
exactly what's going on in
your minds right now.
So what?
What does this have to do with
what came before and what will
come later?
And we're going to see again,
a very, very strange thing
that happens with infinite sums
that does not happen with
finite sums.
Let me lead into that
fairly gradually.
First of all, I claim that
this particular series--
see, again, don't get
misled by this.
It's just a fancy way
of saying what?
1 minus 1/2 plus 1/3, et
cetera, converges.
But because the plus terms
cancel the minus terms, the
pluses cancel the minuses, not
because the terms get small
fast enough.
What I mean by that is this.
Forget about the
signs in here.
Replace each term by
its magnitude.
And by the way, that's where
the name 'absolute'
convergence is going
to come from.
Namely, the magnitude of a term
is its absolute value.
And this is what we're going to
be talking about, but the
idea is this.
If we replace each term
by its magnitude,
we obtain the series.
Summation 'n' goes from 1
to infinity '1 over n'.
And in the last assignment, we
saw in the exercises that this
diverged by the integral test.
In other words, if we leave
out the signs, the series
diverges because evidently these
terms don't get small
fast enough.
Okay.
Let me state a definition.
The definition is simply this.
The series, summation 'n' goes
from 1 to infinity, 'a sub n'
is said to converge absolutely
if the series that you get by
replacing each term by its
magnitude converges.
Now I leave for the
supplementary notes the proof
that if a series converges
absolutely, it converges in
the first place.
In other words, I think it's
rather clear if you look at
this thing intuitively that if
I replace each term by its
magnitude, I'll disregard the
plus and minus signs.
And that resulting series
converges, then the original
series must've converged also
because the terms couldn't be
any bigger than this.
By the way, the formal proof is
kind of messy in places and
so this is why, as I say,
I leave this for the
supplementary notes.
But at any rate that's what we
mean by absolute convergence.
If you're given a series,
you replace each
term by it's magnitude.
If that series converges, we
call the original series
absolutely convergent.
Notice by the way, the tie
in now between absolute
convergence and positive
series.
Namely, by definition, the
absolute value of 'a sub n' is
at least as big as 0.
Consequently, when we're
testing for absolute
convergence, the series that
we test is positive.
And we have tests
for convergence
for positive series.
Now the sequel to definition
one is of course definition
two, and that says what?
A series which converges but
not absolutely is called
conditionally convergent.
In other words, it converges on
the condition that the sine
stay exactly the way they are.
An example of a conditionally
convergent series is the one
that we're dealing
with right now.
Namely, with the pluses and
minuses in there, we just
showed that the series
converges.
However, if we replace each
term by its magnitude, the
resulting series is summation
'1 over n'.
And that as we saw, diverges.
Now the question is, what's
so bad about conditional
convergence?
What difference does it make
whether a series converges
absolutely or conditionally?
Is there any problem
that comes up?
As I said before, a fantastic
subtlety that occurs, a
subtlety that has no parallel
in our knowledge of finite
arithmetic.
The subtlety is this.
In fact, I call it that, the
subtlety of conditional
convergence.
Namely, the sum of a
conditionally convergent series--
and this fantastic--
depends on the order in which
you write the terms.
In other words, if the series
converges, but conditionally
if you change the order of the
terms, surprising as it may
seem, you actually
change the sum.
And the best way to do this
I think at this stage, a
generalization is given in
the supplementary notes.
But the idea is, let me just
do this in terms of the
problem that we were
dealing with.
Let's take the terms of our
conditionally convergent
series, 1 minus 1/2 plus 1/3,
et cetera, and divide them
into two teams.
And if this expression bothers
you, call the teams sets and
that makes it much more
mathematical.
Let the first set
consist of the
positive terms of a series.
Namely, 1, 1/3, 1/5.
And in general, '1 over '2n
minus 1'' where 'n' is any
positive whole number.
The negative numbers of our
team are minus 1/2--
or the set 'N', which I'll call
the negative members is
minus 1/2, minus
1/4, minus 1/6.
In general, minus '1 over 2n'.
Now again, by the integral
test, we saw in our last
lesson that both these series
summation '1 all over '2n
minus 1'' and summation '1 over
2n' diverge to infinity
by the integral test.
Now what my claim is, is that
because both of these two
series diverge, I can now
rearrange my terms to get any
sum that I want.
Well, for example, suppose
somebody says to me, make the
sum come out to be 3/2.
As I'll mention later, there's
nothing sacred about 3/2.
In fact, I'm mentioning that
now but I'll say it again
later for emphasis.
I just wanted to pick a number
that wouldn't be too unwieldy.
But here's what the gist is.
I want to make the
sum at least 3/2.
So what I do is I start with my
positive terms from the set
'P' and add them up.
1 plus 1/3 plus 1/5,
et cetera.
The thing that I'm sure of is
that eventually this sum must
exceed 3/2.
Why do I know that?
Well, 'P' diverges
to infinity.
How could 'P' possibly diverge
to infinity if the sum could
never-- the sum of the terms in
'P' diverges to infinity.
How could that happen if
the sum never got at
least as big as 3/2?
So the idea is I write down all
of these terms, add them
up, until my sum first exceeds
or equals 3/2.
And as I say, this must
happen because the
series diverges to infinity.
Well, in particular, I
observe that 1 plus
1/3 plus 1/5 is 23/15.
And that's now, for the first
time, bigger than 3/2.
What I do next is I annex the
negative members, in other
words, the members of capital
'N', until the
sum falls below 3/2.
Watch what I'm doing here.
I stopped at 1/5.
I have 1 plus 1/3 plus 1/5.
Now I subtract 1/2.
That gives me 31/30 and
that's less than 3/2.
So now my sum is below 3/2.
What I do next is I continue
with 'P' where I left off.
See I left off with 1/5.
I now start tacking on 1/7, 1/9,
1/11, 1/13, et cetera.
Until the sum, again,
exceeds 3/2.
Now how do I know that the
sum has to exceed 3/2?
Well, remember when we add up
all of the members of 'P', we
get a divergent series.
That means the sum increases
without bound.
As we've mentioned many times so
far in our course, that if
you chop off a finite number
of terms from a divergent
series, the remaining
series, what's
left, still must diverge.
In other words, if this series
1 plus 1/3 plus 1/5 plus 1/7
diverges to infinity, the fact
that I chop off those terms
that add up to just an excess
of 3/2, what's left is still
going to diverge to infinity.
So I can keep on
going this way.
What I do is I add on 1/7.
The result turns out to
be 247/210, which is
still less than 3/2.
And to spare you the
gory details--
and believe me, they are gory.
I worked it out myself.
Without a desk calculator
this gets to be a mess.
It turns out that when I add on
1/13, get down to here, the
sum is this, which is
still less than 3/2.
But then I add on 1/15.
The sum gets to be this, which
I simply call 'k'.
That turns out to be
greater than 3/2.
Then you see what I do is
return to my series of
negative terms, tack those on
till the sum falls below.
And what's happening here
pictorially is the following.
You see what happened
was 3/2--
I added on terms till
I exceeded 3/2.
That was 23/15.
Then I get down below 3/2.
Then up again above 3/2.
And still sparing
you the details,
notice what's happening.
Each time that I passed 3/2, I
pass it by less than before
because the terms are getting
smaller in magnitude.
What's happening is and I hope
this crazy little diagram here
serves the purpose.
You see what's happening is
I'm zeroing in on 3/2.
In other words, this particular
rearrangement will
guarantee me that those terms
will add up to 3/2.
Now again, as I said before, 3/2
was not important, though
the arithmetic gets messier.
And again, that's the best
word I can think of.
In other words, I went through
several sheets of paper just
trying to get to the next
stage over here before I
realized it wasn't worth it.
I mean it's something we
can all do on our own.
But the larger number that you
choose, the more terms you're
going to have to add up before
you exceed this.
Don't confuse two things here.
I obviously have to add up an
awful lot of terms of the form
1, 1/3, 1/5, 1/7, 1/9, 1/11
to get, say a million.
But the point is that since
that series diverges,
eventually by going
out far enough--
now far enough might be
billions of terms.
But still a finite number, the
sum will exceed 1 million.
That's the key point.
In other words, I can keep
oscillating around any sum
that I want just by exceeding
it, coming back with a
negative terms, getting less
than that, and alternating
back and forth.
Again, this will be left for
much greater detail for the
supplementary notes
and the exercises.
I'll mention a little bit more
about that in a few minutes.
But the summary so
far is this.
If the series summation 'n' goes
from 1 to infinity, 'a
sub n' is conditionally
convergent, its limit exists.
Let's not forget that.
Its limit exists.
But that limit depends on not
changing the order in which
the terms were given.
In other words, the limit
changes as the order of the
terms is changed.
That is, rearranging the terms
actually changes the series.
And there is nothing in finite
arithmetic that is
comparable to this.
In other words, if you have 50
numbers to add up, or 50
million numbers, or 50 billion
numbers, no matter how you
rearrange those numbers, the
sum exists and is the same
independently of what the
rearrangement is.
This is not comparable
to finite arithmetic.
And the moral is-- and again, I
say this in slang expression
because I want this
to rub off.
I want you to remember this.
Don't monkey with conditional
convergence.
If the series is conditionally
convergent, make sure that you
add the terms in the order
in which they appear.
That if you change the
order, you will
get a different limit.
And what will happen is you'll
get a limit that is the right
answer to the wrong problem.
In other words, changing
the order of the
terms changes the limit.
And this is why conditional
convergence is
particularly annoying.
It means that all of these
things that come natural an
ordinary arithmetic are
lacking in conditional
convergence.
Now, what does the
sequel to this?
The sequel is that all is well
when you have absolute
convergence.
I just wrote this out to make
sure that we have this in
front of us.
The beauty of absolute
convergence is that the sum of
an absolutely convergent series
is the same for every
rearrangement of the terms.
The details are left to the
supplementary notes.
Now, what am I trying to bring
out by all of this?
You see, the beauty of positive
series is that every
time we talk about absolute
convergence, the test involves
a positive series.
In other words, by knowing how
to test positive series for
convergence, we can test
any series for absolute
convergence.
What is the beauty of absolute
convergence?
The beauty of absolute
convergence is that we can
rearrange the terms in any order
that we want if it's
convenient to pick a different
order than another.
And the sum will not depend
on this rearrangement.
You see the point is we are
not saying keep away from
conditionally convergent
series.
In many important applications
you have to come to grips with
conditional convergence.
All we are saying is that if
you want to be able to fool
around numerically with these
series, if you don't have
absolute convergence, you're
in a bit of trouble.
Now you see, the point is that
our textbook does a very good
job in talking about absolute
convergence versus conditional
convergence.
But for some reason, does not
mention the problem of
rearranging terms.
And therefore, much of what I've
talked about today, the
importance of absolute
convergence, is in terms of
rearrangements.
And because this material is
not in the textbook, what I
have elected to do is to put
all of this material that
we've talked about today almost
verbatim except in a
more generalized form, into
the supplementary notes,
supplying whatever proofs are
necessary and whatever
intuitive ideas are necessary.
At any rate, read the
supplementary notes, do the
exercises, and we'll continue
our discussion next time.
And until next time, goodbye.
ANNOUNCER: Funding for the
publication of this video was
provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.